はい 次のパパンチャの世界という妄想の世界ですね
次に我々がやっている悪いことも知った
それがゴチなんです 感情も生まれた
感情はなりたたない 間違ったことを知って感情が生まれたんだから
それからそのことについて頭の中でぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回転する
考え方を考えてから 結論に達して行動行為をする
しかし 元になる概念自体が幻覚なので
人の思考に理解に信頼性はないんです
人間 どんな知識人であっても正しいと信頼しないんです
何を考えていてもどうったことないんです
自分が客観的に正しいことを考えていると思っているのは
精神的に病気な人々なんです
我々はそう思ってないんだけど
やっぱり思ってるんです
それでも 自分考えることは正しいと
我々違と人がガチャガチャ言うと
もしかするととか思ったりするだけなんです
病気の人はそう思わない
あんた知らないだけだよと
私が何でも知ってるぞっていうふうな態度を取るんです
行動行為は間違ってないと言えない
そこでちょっとまたややこしい文章になりました
生命には自分がやっていることは間違っているということは言えませんよ
時々言うでしょうね 私が悪かったとかね
あれってちょっとおかしいんです
なんか不倫でもしてバレたら
もう私が悪かったとものすごく謝ったりしますね
あれは本心じゃないんです
自分を行ってやったことを正しいということ以外知ることはできないんです
その点では女性ははっきりしています
いくら悪いことをしたって認めませんから
男性は弱いんだから あんまりにも責めると悪かった
悪かった 私もうやりませんとか言って謝ったり賛成したりはするんです
女性はそれもない もう何やるかというとことでいきますけど
どちらにしたっても生命だから
女性であろうが男性であろうが
自分やっていることを間違っているとわかるはずがないんです
後で結果見て あるいは社会に責められると
どうしようもないと この際謝ってやろうと
お詫び申し上げましょうと思っちゃうだけ
そこで時々テレビでお詫びをしたところで
なおさら非難を受けたりしますね
また 妄想の行動は感情です
それでなんで限りなく妄想するのかというと
貪瞋痴の感情なんです
見て楽しかったならば
それについてなおさら考えたりするのです
音を聞いてすごい感動が
感動したならば それからそれを忘れないで
なおさら妄想する 自分の頭の中で
だから我々の妄想の衝動は貪瞋痴という感情なんです
だから貪瞋痴の感情で思考することがパパンチャといって
私は一般的に妄想と言っています
感情の海に溺れている
ですから 私たちは感情というすごい海の中にどん底溺れているんです
好ましい感情を作るために生きようとしているんです
その生きるということは
楽しい感情を作ろう 楽しい感情を作ろうと
本を読んだり テレビを見たり
映画を見たり ご飯を食べたり
遊んだり 綺麗な服を着たり
お化粧したり いっぱい頑張ってます
楽しい感情を感じてやろうではないか
ということは 感情に言われる
命じられる通りにしか生きられないのです
自由はないんです 自分の意思精進を感情のために使うんです
人間にも頑張れますよ
人間に意思があります
あるんだけど 感情のために使うんです
例えば私の唇の場合は
今度はちょっと緑っぽい色の方がいいなと
それ感情です そうするとちょこっと薄緑で
この服に合うでしょうと
気持ちいいんだと 感情なんですね
それから頑張るんですよ
どんなデパートで買いましょうかとかね
あるいはどんな なんて言いますか
美容師に 自分が塗っちゃうと気持ち悪くなるんだから
葉っぱみたいに見えるんだから
やっぱりカリスマ美容師に唇に塗ってみようかとかね
頑張ってはいるんですよ
みんな 奴隷はしている
何のために？感情のために
自由だと思っているが
自由ではありません だから生命は自由だと思っているだけ
感情の奴隷です エゴのために
自我のために生きているんです
喜んで自分の意思で貪瞋痴のために生きている
まずみんな喜んで 私は頑張って生きているんだぞと言ってはいるんですけど
貪瞋痴のために生きているんです
あの愚痴から生まれた感情のために
貪瞋痴が笑っているでしょうね
お前の自由って何やと
私言う通りではないかと
食べ 食べなさいと言ったら食べる
寝なさいと言えばすぐ寝る
そういう感情で生きているんです
それからエゴ 私はいるんだというね
エゴのためならどんなひどいこともする
しかし 勘違いも間違いも逆さまの生き方
これちょっと間違いますね
生き方 これは生きるということで
これじゃないね 生き方なので
期待は叶わない 幸福にはならない
苦しみは増えるばかりです
そういうことで 我々もう勘違い
全部 勘違いで生きているんだから
勘違いが作った感情 で生きているんだから
結果が決して良くないんです
どう頑張っても だから期待は叶わない
幸福にはならない 頑張っても頑張っても
頑張った結果が苦しみが増えただけ
ずっと人類そうなんですよ
みんな頑張ってます かなり頑張ってます
しかし 苦しみが増えるだけ
いくら頑張っても期待の結果出てこない
それなのにそれにまた文句を言うんです
それが世界ということ
それに気づき 生き方を変えようとする時々ね
やっぱりこんな調子ではダメだよ
こんなことをやっちゃうと私はダメになるんだよと思う時ありますよ
毎日毎日こんなことばっかしやって何かあるのかとか
気づく場合もあります
幸福になる生き方 正しい生き方などを妄想して見て
道徳 倫理 宗教などを作る
その気づいた人々が これではダメだとか
なんとかしなくちゃと
例えば麻薬やら アルコールならそこで依存症でも依存して喜んで入れてる
ちょっと時間経つと あら
これでは一つも動いてないんだ
不幸になっただけだ だからなんとか変えましょうということで変えようとする
それで宗教が現れるんですよ
しかし またプログラムに問題があるんです
なぜならば 変えようと思うこと自体が愚痴なんです
だってそもそも愚痴だからね
愚痴でひどい目に遭ったところで
なんとか変えなくちゃあかんやと思った
それも愚痴なんです 見るものをすぐ合成するんだから
そういうわけで 宗教がどんな宗教でも仏教は宗教じゃないんですよ
むちゃくちゃガタガタ
そういうわけなんです
当てにならない 信頼できない
はい 貪瞋痴も愚痴であるから起こるというふうに考えてよろしいですか？ 貪瞋痴の
貪瞋痴も 要するに痴は愚痴であるから起こる
そうそうそうそう それでいい
それでいいんです 愚痴でなかったら全部転ぶのはそれ何もないんです
それでいいんです そういうわけで
世の中 皆様は学校でも道徳を学ぶでしょうに
なんかどこかでなんか気に入らんというか
なんかどこかで何でしょうかね
これは とか道徳的になりたいんですよ
しかし 学校の先生にしっかりと教えることはできないんですね
だから 現代日本の学校でやることは
子供たちに考えさせるんです
あんたどう思いますか？この場合は
何かエピソードを教えてあげて
ストーリーを教えてあげて
あんたどう思いますか？あんたどう思いますか？というので
先生は何もしないだから
ああそう ああそう ああそう
はい 終わり 何も教えてない
しかし 衝動は貪瞋痴です
貪瞋痴です あの 例えば宗教を作った人々の衝動も貪瞋痴なんですよ
我らの民族こそ偉大なりというね
今は奴隷ですけど 偉大なりです
だから結局貪瞋痴なんです
悪いことしたくはないがする
それで悪いことで悪い結果になりますよ
そうするとしたくないな
こんなのはと思っちゃいますよ
思ってもそう甘くないんです
やっちゃいます 悪いことをしないでいることっていうのは
そう甘いものじゃないんです
生半可なものじゃないんです
例えば 長い間 まあもう結構楽に食べていた人がいる
食べることは好き やっぱり体に悪いんだからやめますと
そう簡単じゃないんです
自分が今まで喜んできた貪瞋痴だから
やっぱりできません だからダイエットする人々でもかなり厳しく自分を痛めているんですよ
穏やかにできてるわけじゃないんです
たまたま頑張る人々はいますよ
正直に生きてみるそうと思って
一生懸命頑張って正直に生きてみる
しかし ものすごい大変
自分を痛めています 不幸になることはしたくない
したくはないがしてしまう
自由だと思っていたのに
自由ではない 人間は自由ではありません
自分の知の間違いだと気づくことは不可能
だから答えは最後 自分の知が間違いだと
これを直りましょう 直しましょう
この人間というプログラム
コンピューターの中にウイルスが 1個入っているんです
それを退治すればいいんです
でも それに気づくことは不可能です
はい それからちょっと休憩して悪魔を登場させます
はい